let me also start by thanking you
antonio for an incredibly
successful presidency you personally how
skillfully you steered the whole process
on one hand the vaccine strategy i
remember very well that you said we have
to start together on the 27th of
december
and we did it we went through all the
difficulties together
this is this is where you see whether
there is a team or not when you go
through the difficulties
and now we can harvest the success
together the second point
is the eu certificate
record time in which it has been
ready now 26 member states are connected
so far and it's ready to go for the
first of july
by the end of the week we will have
delivered over 424 million doses
by thus we exceed our delivery targets
for quarter two
and we will have by the end of the week
almost 60 percent
of adults in the european union that
have received at least one dose
and we will have almost 40 percent that
will be fully vaccinated
this is a big step forward but it is
also necessary
because we are worried about the delta
variant
if you look at the uk there the delta
variant is by now
the dominant one 90 of the infections
are the delta variant it is rapidly
progressing also speeding up here
the good news in that is that
we see that the vaccination protects
double vaccination protects very
effectively against the delta variant
and single vaccination or single shot at
the beginning
gives at least a reduction of severe
illness
but with this delta variant we need to
stay vigilant
we need to stay very coordinated with
restrictive measures are concerned
the typical things like masks and
distance have to stay in place
and we need to vaccinate vaccinate
vaccinate that's the best strategy
against
these variants we have looked at the
lessons learned and i will not go in
detail
because the whole report is there but
leaders came out
very supportive of the commission's
proposals so now we're going to
implement
what we have seen as
weaknesses or where we should step
forward
together in the health sector
you